hey everybody welcome back to the
channel today we're focusing on a pepper
that's spicy versatile and a favorite in
many kitchens the Sano pepper whether
you're a seasoned Gardener or just
starting out this pepper is a must have
for anyone who loves growing their own
food let's explore everything you need
to know about the Sorano
pepper did you know that the sorrano
peppers can be up to five times hotter
than jalapenos soranos range between
10,000 and 25,000 Scoville heat units
making them a great choice if you're
looking to add a serious kick to your
dishes and unlike some chili varieties
sanos retain their bright fresh flavor
even as they mature making them perfect
for fresh Salsas and hot sauces the
sorrano pepper is native to the
mountainous regions of playo and hildo
in Mexico its name comes from the
Spanish word for mountains reflecting
its Origins it has been cultivated in
Mexico for hundreds of years and remains
a staple in Mexican Cuisine particularly
in dishes like pic dealo Salas and
sauces today surrounds are popular
worldwide for their heat and rich flavor
often used for fresh rather than dried
like other hot peppers
Sorano pepper plants are bushy and
compact typically growing until about 2
to 3et tall the peppers themselves are
slender cylindrical and usually about 1
to 2 in long though they can grow up to
4 in when immature surrounds are green
but they ripen to vibrant shades of red
orange and yellow depending on the
variety these peppers grow in clusters
on the plant and can be harvested at any
stage of ripeness depending on your heat
preference if you're ready to grow surr
peppers is important to provide them
with the right conditions sanos thrive
in warm climates and need plenty of
sunshine at least 6 8 hours of full sun
each day they prefer well- draining lomy
soil with a pH between 6.0 and 7.0 plant
your Sano seeds endur about 8 to 10
weeks before the last frost dat once the
ceilings have grown to about 4 in tall
and the outdoor temperatures
consistently stay above 60° fhe then you
can transplant water the plants
regularly keeping the soil consistently
moist space the plants about 18 to 24 in
apart add a layer of mulch around the
base of plants which can help retain
moisture and keep the roots cool during
hot weather serto Peppers benefit from
companion planting and there are several
vegetables and herbs that grow well
alongside them good companions include
Tomatoes carrots basil and marry Golds
these plants help DET tear pests and can
help improve the overall health of your
garden for example basil can enhance the
flavor of your sanos while Mar gos help
repel nematodes which can damage your
pepper Roots avoid planting the peppers
near fennel as it can stunt the growth
of Sano plants one special behavior of
Sano plants is ability to continuously
produce fruit throughout the growing
season provided they're regularly
harvested the more you pick the more
peppers a plant will produce s peppers
are also relatively resistant to Pest
and disease making them a
low-maintenance crop for most home
gardens however keep an eye out for
common Garden pests like aphid spites
and white flies which can occasionally
affect pepper
plants Sorano peppers are incredibly
versatile in the kitchen because they
hold on to their crispness and even when
cooked they're great in Salsas guacamole
stir fries and pickled recipes you can
also use them in fresh STS or roast them
to bring out their sweetness sral are
packed with capsacin the compound
responsible for the heat cap sa has
numerous health benefits including
boosting metabolism reducing
inflammation and improving circulation
they're also a great source of vitamin C
and A both of which are important for
immune health and skin Health serto
peppers are a perfect addition to any
Garden offering not only their signature
heat but also a long growing season and
an abundance of uses in the kitchen
they're easy to grow productive and a
fantastic choice for anyone who loves a
little Spice in their life thanks for
tuning in today if you found this video
helpful don't forget to like share and
subscribe for more gardening tips and
plant profile and as always always happy
growing
[Music]